como vio este discurso de gustavo petro
realmente primero es un discurso como es
el muy instructivo busca salir
totalmente de lo que sería un programa
de un discurso normal de un presidente
de la onu declara la guerra a la selva
que lo que el mundo ha hecho es
realmente llama la atención metro quiere
focalizarse y generar un foco de
atención en alguna de sus aseveraciones
son realmente
importantes que lo más venenoso si es la
cocaína el petróleo o el carbón son
preguntas que él hace en definitiva hace
algunas
afirmaciones que son peregrinas cuando
dice que la cocaína han matado muy poca
gente por sobredosis en otros países en
definitiva lo que él quiere es poner el
foco en lo que sería un programa que en
eso tiene razón no ha dado resultado en
cuanto a lo que sería la guerra en la
droga en colombia y después resaltar
muchísimo qué es lo que le pasa al mundo
ese es el eje del discurso de petro en
su país y para afuera donde el
consumismo
no genera felicidad total en definitiva
la droga hoy más importante que tiene el
mundo según petro es el consumismo y el
propio mercado y él hace algunos algunos
cuestionamientos en lo que es el mundo
en general adorando al petróleo al
carbón y al dinero está en esta
situación
ilimitada que tiene el hombre de
acumular y acumular y acumular y como
algunos países están adoleciendo de
problemas de drogas y esos son los
grandes consumidores en busca de que los
países más avanzados que son además los
consumidores de cocaína más importantes
reaccionen y dejen de ser esa fuente
permanente de compra de este tipo de
sustancias hay una crítica muy
importante al gobierno de eeuu con el
tema de 30 a nilo etcétera etcétera no
producido por colombia y que sí que
genera mayores adicciones en todo esto y
después como siempre
alguna crítica a lo que sería el orden
mundial pero en definitiva
vemos el petró algo que no lo hemos
visto hasta acá
no hubo una condena al tema rusia
ucrania pidió paz nada más eso lo
diferencia de otros presidentes hasta el
número